ils ne positionnent pas ce que tu es vraiment
bon voir Amana vu des trucs petit Fuqua
protéique Oceano si tu vois les trucs c'est
ici étonnamment la politique xalapa sur
pardonner facilement possible libérer la voiture
avant ventouse avec un clap ouais gros mauve
faire yamaha de - ce que tu  made in a été
ajouté ok boom balloon sur SRS teleme
off-roaders rock sur Avinash déco Jimmy
Page Allah c'est Montgomery Scott right
Scotty ouais je vois que l'
une des choses excitantes pour moi à venir
sur ce film était de présenter un tout
nouveau personnage à l'équipage  Je suis Jayla
vient d'une race très forte d'extraterrestres
physiquement extrêmement forte elle est
incroyablement dure indépendante débrouillarde
vous m'aidez et je vous aide nous aimons l'
idée que Scotty trouve une sorte de
jeune ingénieur adepte qui a une
compétence mécanique qui l'impressionne j'ai branché le
petit  boîte dans la cellule de puissance et la
petite souris la font chanter c'est très
intelligent, elle est ce personnage fougueux, drôle, drôle et
dur qui devient un
allié très important pour  il l'a fait équipe avec
moi, elle est assez défensive
toute seule et elle s'est
protégée tout ce que je sais, c'est que nous avons une meilleure
chance avec vous Jayla a ce sentiment d'
innocence mais aussi cette qualité de
force qui n'est pas fabriquée
comme Désolé mate
letici  siffler